it's actually really related to what I
understand about neuroplasticity now
because there's a period of time where
you make new Connections in your brain
and you build up this new pathway and
it's almost like there's a Tipping Point
where that pathway becomes the way that
you think now and your old ways of
thinking get overwritten so one of the
analogies that I could use is if you
came up to a field that was knee-high
and grass then the first time you walk
across that field you're going to be
pushing that grass down with your feet
but if you walk that same path every day
for a week you probably would have
trodden a sort of pathway through the
grass that you can walk through easily
if you then said okay I'm going to lay
down some wooden slabs to make it even
easier to walk along there and then you
built that further and you maybe like
cemented them in then eventually you
could make a path that's so easy to walk
down that it takes no effort at all and
it's exactly the same in the brain when
you learn something new we're so
bombarded with information in the modern
day that what you would read in a
newspaper in one day today is the amount
of information that some D would have
received in their lifetime a hundred
years ago the brain naturally filters
out things that aren't vital to our
survival but if we do something like
create a vision board or visualize
something that we want then we're
training the brain more to be aware of
the things that we really want so then
when it does the selective filtering it
doesn't filter out that person that
could introduce you to somebody about
your business or that person that could
introduce you to somebody for a date
that means noticing and then grasping
opportunities that can move you closer
to your goal
hey friends welcome back to Deep dive
the weekly podcast where every week it
is my immense privilege and pleasure to
sit down with academics and authors and
entrepreneurs and creators and other
inspiring people and we find out how
they got to where they are and what we
can learn from them to help apply to
help live our own best lives what you're
about to hear is a discussion between me
and Dr Tara swart Tara has a PHD in
neuropharmacology she also trained and
worked as a psychiatrist in the UK's
National Health Service for about seven
years before leaving medicine and
becoming an executive advice coach type
person and then her career morphed into
doing talks and exploring the world of
neuroplasticity and the world of brain
care and the world of how we can learn
from neuroscience and psychology and
endocrinology and like immunology and
microbiology and putting all these
sciency things together to help improve
the ways that our brains function oh
she's also Chief science officer for
Heights which is a brain care supplement
company which I've also invested in we
had the founder of heights on the
podcast a couple of seasons ago in the
conversation we talk about the somewhat
circuitous path she took to get to the
career that she is at now and we spend
most of the conversation talking about
what are the practical things that we
can learn from the world of Neuroscience
from the field of neuroplasticity that
we can apply to our own lives to help
reduce our stress to help increase our
brain's performance to help make it
easier to learn stuff super interesting
conversation I hope you'll enjoy it as
much as I did all right Tara thank you
so much for coming on
um I would love to sort of just get into
a little bit of the backstory so you
were are have been a sort of a
psychiatrist a neuropharmacologist
neuroscientist PhD you're now Chief
science officer at Heights you have your
own executive advice business where you
kind of apply these insights and and I
guess coach other people where did all
this start how did we end up here yeah
so that does sound quite messy when you
put it like that so maybe that's pretty
cool yeah if we put it in date order
then I like you I guess from school I
went to
um medical school in London did two
years of pre-clinical
did the intercalated BSC
um and then from then got offered to
stay on and do a PhD in
neuropharmacology which I did for three
years and then it was time to get out of
London so I went to Oxford to complete
Medical School the clinical part
um did my first surgical job there
returned to London and did my medical
job and then started training in
Psychiatry at the Royal free Hospital
and over the next that that's sort of
six years I worked in the west London
Mental Health Trust mostly and I also
worked abroad in Australia and Bermuda
then in 2007 I quit medicine
um moved back from Bermuda to the UK
did a six-month coaching course and then
in 2008 and worked in an office
um really going from sort of
been quite an experienced psychiatrist
at that point to being the absolute
bottom of the pile no business contacts
um
my PowerPoint skills apparently weren't
upscratch for what they were needed at
that point and then in 2008 started my
own freelance practice as a coach and
sort of two or three years later made
that into a company and did speaking and
writing
um and then a little bit after that a
year or two after that started teaching
MIT Sloan so applying Neuroscience to
business and Leadership and then at some
point I'm not sure of the exact date
maybe four or five years ago Dan and his
co-founder Joel
um found me on social media so great
place to like headhunt people and we're
looking for a chief science officer for
Heights which is a brain care supplement
and I think all of the you know PhD in
neuroscience and medical doctor
obviously
um were important but the thing that
really jailed us together was that when
I was traveling and I was traveling a
lot for business at that time I was
taking 10 sometimes up to 20 bottles of
supplements with me for my travel it was
very stressful I was enduring a lot of
jet lag I was going to very different
places having to switch mode between
whether I was coaching or speaking and I
wanted to make sure and and when I was
traveling I couldn't always eat as
healthily as I did when I was at home
um so I grow my own food and only eat
organic and I cook from scratch every
day yeah so when I couldn't do that I
was even more aware of making sure that
I got all the nutrients that I feel that
I need for my brain and that get very
depleted by stress and travel
so um when I heard about the idea of
having
one capsule it's a double capsule that
had pretty much everything that I would
want to take in it
I wanted to be part of that and from the
beginning I was banging on about
magnesium probiotic and and now we are
bringing those on as bolt-on products to
the original brain care supplement oh
okay so so many kind of interesting
points along that Journey yeah we zoom
in can we zoom into 2007. why did you
why did why did you leave medicine what
was going on I've been thinking about it
for two years
because it's a really big decision both
personally and professionally
I loved Psychiatry and I really cared
about my patients and I felt that for a
lot of my colleagues it was a lifestyle
choice
so to leave knowing that
people who depend on me who waited for
months to see me children the elderly
you know really vulnerable people
I had to feel that
I was definitely going to have more
impact on people by doing whatever I was
going to do next
but obviously the other side of the coin
of that was that
I'd done my PhD in Neuroscience thinking
I was going to become a neurologist when
I went to the clinical School
I felt like that interaction with people
wasn't going to be enough for me with
Neurology and Psychiatry where I started
to really delve into people hearing
voices that weren't there
um that your brain could play a trick on
you in such a way that you couldn't
trust yourself that felt like a really
important thing to be part of and try to
help with and care about and understand
but what I realized as I moved through
the different Specialties so I did child
psychiatry I did forensic psychiatry
vulnerable females the elderly rehab
learning disabilities and I traveled
around the world with it too
was that
if I remained in that job for the next
30 or 40 years I wasn't going to get
enough intellectual stimulation or
challenge
to keep me happy and at my best and so I
had that terrible dilemma of feeling
like I could do this really well for the
rest of my life but
I wouldn't be living my best life if I
did that and so when I finally made the
decision to quit and that was after I'd
gone through a hundred options of other
things that I could do instead of
medicine because when you go to medical
school when you're 18 and then you're a
doctor for six or seven years that's and
I was at Medical School essentially for
nine years
you don't think that you can do anything
else so it's you know it's a really big
deal to leave so I finally found
Executive coaching as
the thing that was very much about goal
orientation and focus and determination
but also quite Zen so that seemed to fit
with my psychological skills and when I
went to the chief of Psychiatry and said
as you'll know you know you have to have
a form signed by all your bosses for the
last two years to prove that you're not
leaving because you've done something
terrible
um when I asked him to sign the form he
said to me this is such a great loss to
us because you could do this job in your
sleep and I think that was the phrase
that I needed to hear which was I didn't
want to be asleep for the rest of my
life I wanted to be challenged and do
new and different things
and at that stage I thought I was just
going to be a coach obviously I've done
like loads of different things since
then but
yeah i s i
um moved countries came and did the
coaching qualification had to learn to
listen in a way that was completely
different to when you're just thinking
about what diagnosis you're going to
make
um
yeah I think that's does that answer
your question yeah it does oh so it's
how okay how how much of the decision to
leave was
lifestyle versus kind of intellectual
stimulation I guess I'm asking because I
I mean I still still know about half my
friends are medics and the biggest gripe
anyone ever has is the lifestyle
um usually
yeah so that wasn't a thing for me
because as I mentioned a lot of people
go into Psychiatry because of the
lifestyle so it's not you know the
on-calls aren't as hard and ever since I
was at Medical School
um or not medical school but in my first
year when I before I got married and I
still had my maiden name which was
Banerjee people used to pray for a
Banerjee night on call because I
literally never got woken up and I
actually worried when I got married and
I changed my surname that my luck might
change but it didn't and when I had my
sort of six monthly review with my
consultant in psychiatry
he said you know what's going well what
are you concerned about and I said I'm
concerned I'm not getting enough
experience on call because
I I go around the wards I check
everything's okay I go to sleep I wake
up the next morning he said I wouldn't
complain about that
um so and then in Australia I could do a
lot of phone consultations overnight or
it was a 15-minute drive you know it
wasn't
that wasn't an issue for me the
lifestyle suited me
um I was able to travel
I didn't get too much sleep disruption
I'm obsessed with sleep so that would
have been a problem if I had sleep
disruption so for me it was definitely
and and in the end when I felt like
how how would I really be able to feel
good about the fact that I was leaving
behind patients that I could have given
so much care to
it came down to the fact that in
NHS or you know government Psychiatry
you're dealing with people
in the lowest socioeconomic groups whose
families have abandoned them who don't
have jobs whose children get taken away
from them and so your impact is really
high on that one person but it doesn't
go much further than that and I felt
that if I went into Executive coaching
and I worked with really senior people
who impact
their teams and a company and have
Corporate social responsibility you know
role models in society
that
I would be able to touch more people by
doing that than I would by staying as an
individual doctor
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and very excitingly this episode
is brought to you by Heights Heights is
a brain care smart supplement that I've
actually been taking for the last 12
months ever since I became friends with
Dan marisota who was the founder of
heights and who we had on the podcast in
season one and this season of the
podcast we're also featuring Dr Tara
swart who is a neuroscientist and
psychiatrist so what is height well it's
a brain care smart supplement basically
it is a supplement you take two of them
every morning like I do it's like these
two little capsules which have omega-3
oil in them and they've got a bunch of
multi vitamins as well they have all of
the details on the website in every
single ingredient that they've got is
super high quality and the great thing
is that just by taking two of these
capsules every morning like I do you get
all of the essential micronutrients that
you need without having to deal with
drinking sludge or anything fancy like
that so the great thing about Heights is
that even if you don't have one of these
absolutely perfect diets at least you
know you have your bases covered in
terms of the micronutrients that you
need it's very easy to sign up you just
go to yourheits.com and then you sign up
to the thing and it's a mail order they
get to you every month or in three month
packets and if you use the coupon code
Ali 15 that's ali15 at checkout then
you'll get 15 off your first three
months of subscription I've been
subscribed to this for the last 12
months I also happen to be an investor
in the company because I believe in the
product and I love how they're fully
evidence-based and absolutely everything
they do and if you're interested in the
evidence base behind all like 20
different ingredients that they've got
here you can check them out on the
website and that'll be linked in the
video description and in the show notes
so thank you so much to Heights for
sponsoring this episode how did you land
on Executive coaching like as I it's
only recently I even knew the term
existed how did you discover that that
was a thing and that that's the career
you want to go down so one of my best
friends at school who studied you know
cycle psychology and philosophy at
University and then also did a PhD in
the Neuroscience area she went on to
work for McKinsey and I went on to work
for the NHS and that's where I Our Lives
having been at school together diverged
quite significantly
and
she encouraged me to look into the idea
of coaching and sent me lots of Articles
to read about it and during that two
years that I was thinking about whether
I would do something different we spent
a lot of time sitting in Green Park
talking about business psychology and so
I really owe it to her to have
introduced me to even the idea of that
and I was originally going to go and
work as a coach for her she was going to
set up a business but then that fell
through and I literally heard these
words come out of my mouth before I
decided really and I was like well I'm
going to do it anyway
that I think that's when I when I I
looked for the next opening for the
coaching course and I think I'd
it was either like quit now and would
give you a three months notice and you
could do it soon or you'd have to wait
another six months and I just I just
quit and I think
it's actually really related to what I
understand about neuroplasticity now
because there's a period of time where
you make new Connections in your brain
and you build up this new pathway and
it's almost like there's a Tipping Point
where that pathway becomes the way that
you think now and your old ways of
thinking get overwritten
so I feel like that two years of really
thinking about should I leave what could
I do instead how can I justify this to
myself and feel good about it
um
when something came along that was the
right thing I was just able to say okay
I'm quitting my job I'm moving countries
I'm starting this course on a thing that
I I've only read a few papers about but
I don't really know what it is
um and yeah I just did us that's
interesting so like just like this this
time last week I I happened to be at San
pancreas station and um someone came up
to me who recognized me from the videos
and she had been a she'd been in
medicine for 14 years and was leaving to
become a coach and was in the middle of
doing a coaching qualification and so
it's like and and just earlier today I
was interviewing
um another friend Simon who's also a
coach and it's just like we a lot of
interactions with people people who have
found coaching as like a career
um and even though I feel like I was
quite clued into the
alternative career thingy just like
being a coach just never even even
vaguely occurred to me but now I find
that you know through the key through
YouTube and through the podcast like a
lot of people have emailed me like hey
do you do one-on-one coaching and I'm
always like nope but it's always like a
question mark on the end of it
yeah so okay so you left Psychiatry and
did you have like a backup how were you
planning to make money while doing the
coaching thing were you thinking I can
do a Locum every now and then what was
the thought process
um so interestingly about the Locum
and I'm not saying this is right for
everyone at all a lot of people have a
side job or a part-time job when they're
starting up a new business I think the
decision to leave medicine was so
emotive for me that I had to burn my
boats I was like there's no way back I
will never do a Locum I have to make
this work
and there were times that I couldn't pay
my bills and people said Tara please
just go and do one weekend you'll earn
enough money to pay your rent for six
months and you'll you know don't have to
worry about your bills and I I said no
but
that probably says quite a lot about the
kind of person I am and that's why I
qualified it by saying that's not for
everyone so I was married at the time
that I made the decision and we did have
an agreement that he would you know
support me
for a period of time whilst I did the
course and I once I knew I was going to
quit even though there wasn't much time
I started saving you know
um unfortunately we got divorced during
that time so that um but actually he was
you know super supportive and still um
helped me for as long as I needed and
would have continued to help me for
longer but there was a point in time
where I said I don't need right yeah and
so you built up your coaching business I
guess from the ground up since then and
that's kind of what you do now with
along with the height stuff um no it's
really changed so I was doing like all
coaching at the beginning and then and
that was
2008 9 10 around 2010
Neuroscience became a buzz Topic in
business and Leadership and people
wanted speakers and there weren't that
many I mean as a former psychiatrist I
fell very much in the gap between
psychologists that become coaches and
business people that become coaches and
I didn't belong anywhere
but suddenly
um where it was like well who can talk
about Neuroscience in business
I was like well I can
um so I started doing a few talks
thinking
they would just lead to me getting
coaching clients and then I realized
very quickly that that could be a
revenue generator for my business and it
went like this literally like well my
money was coming from coaching and none
was coming from speaking and then it
went like that all the time okay yeah
very open-ended question like how how do
Neuroscience in business go to go
together well basically if you're in
business if you're a leader if you're a
senior executive if you're a in you know
a Trader then you're being paid to use
your brain but if if you haven't studied
Neuroscience you probably don't know as
much as you need to know to get the most
out of that really important organ
so I can go in and do a general one-hour
talk that sort of tells people about how
their brain works how to get the best
out of it
um you know all the foundational factors
that contribute to Peak Performance and
brain optimization and good mental
health and well-being
um and then in coaching I can either
take that approach which is here's the
sort of General ideas for improving your
well-being and therefore your your brain
performance or I can find out what
somebody's issue is and it could be
stress it could be travel it could be
doubting themselves when they're about
to make a trading decision
um and then I can go and look at the
research and find something specific to
help them overcome that particular brain
issue that they might have okay so I
wonder if we can start general then so
like let's say someone's listening to
this or even me because I actually don't
know much about this
um what are the things that we can do to
improve our brain performance
so we talk about things like
rest which is sleep and also sort of
downtime nutrition is super important so
the brain is obviously a tiny proportion
of your body weight
um and only weighs a few kilos but it
uses up up to 30 of the breakdown
products of what you eat so when you're
asleep your brain is is eating up 20 of
what you ate that day
when you're at work
um and focused on something it's using
up about a quarter of what you eat and
when you're stressed it's easing up up
to 30 percent oh well yeah and so
obviously people think what should I eat
if I want to be healthy generally or I
want to lose weight or I want to build
muscle mass but the sorts of people that
you know like you and the people that I
work with
aren't thinking enough about what should
I be eating so I can make the best
decisions today what should I be eating
so I can solve complex problems what
should should I be eating so I can
understand what's going on like in terms
of interpersonal Communication in my
teeth with my team for example
and then there's everything from
hydration exercise
um breathing mindfulness curiosity like
there's there's so many factors that
contribute
to brain health and
they're probably not dissimilar to
things as a doctor that you would know
contribute to cardiovascular health or
gastrointestinal Health but
you know we at Heights feel that if you
approach everything with a brain care
first attitude then you're kind of
taking care of the rest of the stuff
like if you eat and drink in a way
that's good for your brain your skin and
your hair are going to look nicer I mean
and I that sounds like a such a girly
thing to say but people make a lot of
really important choices based on
what they look like and and that's fine
and that probably has like beneficial
effects on our in our brains and our
guts as well but considering this organ
is so energy hungry and it's so
important in terms of everything else
that happens in your body
I feel like we need to flip that
narrative so that it's starting with
okay what can I what things can I do
today that are going to be the best for
my brain just a quick message from one
of our sponsors and we'll get right back
to the episode and this episode is very
kindly brought to you by short form
short form is the world's best service
that summarizes books but it's way more
than just book summaries they almost
have a whole study guide for every book
that they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books in lifestyle
and communication basically any genre of
like non-fiction personal development is
self-helpy stuff that will help you
level up your life it's all there in
short form short form Publishers new
book guides and articles every week and
if you're a subscriber then you get to
vote on what book they cover next and in
fact through that system I have voted
for various books that they've then
turned into summaries for example one
book I've recently reread through the
short form book guide is no rules rules
by Reed Hastings who's one of the
founders of Netflix now I listen to the
audiobook of no rules rules a while ago
and I was sort of applying it to my team
at the time but since then my team has
grown and the challenges have changed
and so I used short forms guide to
revisit some of the key lessons from no
rules rules around building the
appropriate team culture anyway if any
of that sounds up your street and you
would like to sign up to the world's
best service that summarizes books then
head over to shortform.com forward slash
deep dive and that will give you a
completely free five-day trial and you
can try out the service to your heart's
content that link will also be in the
video description and in the show notes
and thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode I wonder if we
can start with the nutrition thing then
and I guess what should me and I guess
listeners and viewers be thinking about
when it comes to nutrition like oh or is
it all just the stuff that everyone kind
of knows but doesn't implement or do you
feel like there's actually a knowledge
Gap in an understanding Gap or if it's
just a actually Implement implementing
the things that we all know we probably
should do I like to think there's a bit
of both so I think there's a lot of
things that are in the public domain
that people are aware of that we all
know we should be doing but we're not
necessarily always doing but there are
definitely fun Neuroscience facts that I
can throw in that that I would guess
maybe even you haven't heard of so
should we try yeah perfect yeah okay so
um I would say like level one is that
you eat three healthy meals a day and
and maybe you snack in between if you
need to and when I say healthy mostly
plant-based you know maybe some fish and
eggs minimal amounts of of other types
of meat
um
foods that contain high amounts of water
and good fats so a bit of dairy
fatty fish nuts and seeds berries I mean
I'm already going above level one I
would say with some of those but but you
know three healthy meals a day that kind
of food question on that front yeah
intermittent fasting yeah yeah so level
two oh but that's level two okay if
you're not eating healthily generally
yeah if you're not sleeping around
seven to eight hours fifteen a night
drinking enough water making sure you're
not sedentary don't bother with
intermittent fasting you need to have
those foundations correct if you're
doing all that good stuff and maybe even
meditating then you can take it to the
next level which is
um the first level would be time
restricted eating so for example I only
eat between 12 noon and 8 pm
so I'm essentially doing a 16 hour fast
overnight which has all sorts of
benefits on longevity and cancer risk
reduction and and once you get used to
it it's also it's also good for your
your mental performance
and then the third level which I'm
considering doing again the rest of this
year but I haven't quite got there yet
is what I think is proper intermittent
fasting which is that for two days of
the week you reduce your calorie intake
to for women 500 calories and for men
600 calories a day and the other days of
the week you eat normally
but in all three of those stages you
still have to be eating the kinds of
foods that I mentioned and so this is
tell me whether you knew this or not but
for in terms of brain optimization
eating dark-skinned Foods is much better
than just eating general you know the
leafy greens or the salads or skinned
yeah I mean like blueberries rather than
strawberries or raspberries okay purple
sprouting broccoli rather than green
broccoli black beans and black chickpeas
rather than cannellini beans or normal
chickpeas
so the skin and things like eggplant as
well I think this the the
um in the skin of Darker foods and
actually you'll like this because it
does include good quality coffee oh
perfect and dark chocolate that's over
80 cocoa
um there are substance is called
anthocyanins that are really powerful
antioxidants and they contribute to
something called neurogenesis so there's
three ways of growing your brain if you
like and I and I use that in a as a
metaphor
um
and the hardest one in adults is
for embryonic nerve cells to actually
grow into neurons and connect up with
other neurons in your brain and so
aerobic exercise and foods that contain
high levels of anthocyanins can
contribute to neurogenesis it's going
for a run is good going for a run is
good
um if you're feeling guilty because you
haven't been going for a run then when
you do regular aerobic exercise the cell
turnover is sort of 13 14
of neurogenesis if you have haven't been
doing exercise for some time and you
start again it can actually be up to 30
so to me that's the perfect excuse for
every time I fall off my schedule of
exercise and I start again that I'm
really boosting my neurogenesis but you
know I'm never sedentary but I'm not
always doing like full on aerobic at
sort of more high intensity exercise so
okay yeah so one mechanism is
neurogenesis the one that makes our
brain quick grow what are what are the
other two so neurogenesis is the
embryonic cells growing into new neurons
the next one is synapse synaptic
connection which is already existing
neurons connecting up with each other to
make stronger Pathways and the third one
which you'll be well aware of is
myelination which is a fatty substance
that coats some Pathways in the brain
and body and there's a reason that so
and that leads to faster conduction of
electrical signals along those Pathways
and there are reasons that we have some
Pathways that are myelinated and some
that aren't like for example
if you put your hand in a fire
your reflex to snap your hand out of the
fire is a fast myelinated pathway but
your pain
um pathways are non-myelinated because
if you were incapacitated by the pain of
burning your hand you wouldn't be able
to move or escape from the you know the
threat kind of thing
but what in terms of what we're talking
about which is brain performance
um
basically repetition
can lead to more myelination which means
that that pathway becomes a faster
conducting pathway for you so something
like resisting the urge to you know eat
junk food or
um like there's crisps so some crisps
over there and last night I made the bad
choice to eat the crisps and Gordon kind
of looked at me and like sighed because
I was like whoa there's 200 calories in
these and today I didn't I decided to
leave the chips as they were well that
could be to do with time of day because
your willpower also reduces so during
the day oh yeah maybe
but I mean for me it's mostly about
stimulus control which is that I don't
keep those things yeah it's a yeah it's
a lot easier to resist the chocolate
cake if it's not there
um Okay so we've got neurogenesis from
embryonic cells we've got the synaptic
connections and we've got mother nation
yeah such a pleasure talking to you
because most people are like what were
those things again
how do we tangibly impact those things
so we talked about repetition equals
more myelination and I guess this is
where sort of repetition when it comes
to learning stuff as well like space
repetition over time equals more mother
nation presumably
um what other things can we do to Quick
growth brain so I think in real life
we don't necessarily need to know which
underlying physiological mechanism we're
affecting but we need to know we need to
see the real life result if I'm trying
to learn something or do something
differently and it's working or it's not
working I think the easiest way to just
think about those three is that
the myelination is like something that
you're already good at that it would be
really easy for you to pick up for it to
become your superpower basically
um so for instance and this sounds and I
don't
I don't mean this in a boastful way but
I've got a friend who's a professor of
Neuroscience who plays in a band and I
really admire him for being so good at
an instrument but it really irks him
that I can just learn a new language so
easily so that's like one of my
superpowers
and so I have learned five languages in
my lifetime I'm not fluent in all of
them at the moment but if someone said
to me you know you know do you want to
learn a new language I I'd say yeah
because I'll probably be quite good at
that
um but there are lots of other things
that would be much harder for me to
become good at so
that would be for for me that would be
like my a grade subject okay when I take
that unwillingly because I'd probably
find it not too difficult and I'd
probably be quite good at it so think
about what that might be for you hmm and
then
synaptic connection is more like your B
plus which is something that you're not
bad at at all but you don't love and it
doesn't come really easy and naturally
but if you worked really hard you could
make that into an a grade
and then neurogenesis in adulthood
although There Are embryonic cells
around the hippocampus which is where
you know we lay down memories and
learning it's way less than in children
so that would be like
well I did I did this I don't feel like
me taking up golf
um I was really bad at it it took me
ages to improve I would have had to give
up my day job to become you know any
level of decent at it so
um it's it's not wise really in
adulthood to take on a learning that's
so difficult that it's going to detract
from your day-to-day brain performance
um and in that middle category for me I
would probably put something like
let the Tango quite well not amazingly
improved at tennis taught myself
keyboard you know but I'm never going to
be like performing or anything so that's
that's the easiest way to think about
those in your mind like which of those
mechanisms might I be working on because
it's really to do with the level of how
difficult it would be for you so would
it be fair to say then that like let's
say when you're at University the things
you found yourself naturally good at are
probably the things that you will find
it easier to remain good at or be good
at when it comes to adulthood like for
you presumably those languages but not
golf
so you mean when I was except at
University well interestingly did you
know that in the first
in the pre-clinical part of medical
school
you learn more new words than a language
student does in their whole degree
really yeah because there's so many
Greek and Latin based words and
um so I would say probably we're both
really good at languages yeah yeah so
I want to be a bit careful about saying
when you're at University because by
then you've already narrowed down what
you're doing quite a lot so it might
even be what when you're at school there
yeah and it might even just be what
you're interested in outside of Academia
yeah
um
so I do believe in identifying what your
passions are usually aligns with what
your strengths are maybe not always but
thinking about it that way is a really
good way to think about it and not kind
of trying to be good at everything play
to your strengths the Neuroscience
really supports that okay
and so
to what extent is this relevant when
you're for like coaching coaching people
in the sort of this executive advice
space
that's such a good question because
actually I often get dragged in because
people say
this person is really really really good
at what they do but they've got no
emotional intelligence and unless you
can help them change we're gonna have to
get rid of them it's that bad like I
mean not so much recently but more when
I was coaching like around the time of
the financial crisis
and the consequences of that there were
still people that would
shout go red in the face make people cry
like make people not you know want to
quit their team and stuff like that so
that was almost me having to do like
neurogenesis with them but
um
I would definitely
help them to see what they're really
good at and and play to that because
those are quick wins and in coaching I
would want people to get quick wins
because then they'll believe that they
can change things and that I can help
them
and a lot of coaching is about building
up that relationship of trust so that
it's okay for them to try something and
fail because they know that you'll just
still be there encouraging and helping
them learn from it
um it's really it's a very like
um
privilege like special kind of
relationships it's intense it's
one-on-one it can be very emotional
but the main thing I found that helped
these senior guys who are pretty much at
the top of their career ladder
um don't really have to worry about
finances why would they
put in that effort that it's going to
take for them to now change their
behavior
and a lot of them said
it's too hard I don't understand what I
need to do I don't understand what
people mean when they say you need to be
more caring or understanding or
emotionally intelligent and I don't I
don't know if I can do it and so I
explained neuroplasticity to them like
building a brick wall or building a
pathway
and so one of the analogies that I could
use is if you came up to a field that
was like knee-high and grass then the
first time you walk across that field
you're going to be pushing that grass
down with your feet and maybe some of it
would bounce back up but if you walk
that same path every day for a week you
probably would have trodden a sort of
you know just a a pathway through the
grass that you can walk through easily
if you then said okay I'm going to lay
down some wooden slabs to make it even
easier to walk along there
and then you built that further and you
maybe like cemented them in or whatever
then eventually you could make a path
that's so easy to walk down that it
takes no effort at all and it's exactly
the same in the brain when you learn
something new
and so what I would get these guys to do
is
I'd say go home tonight
and listen to your child for five
minutes without interrupting them and
not having your phone on your person
and that alone was so eye-opening for
people because they were never doing it
they were always asking how did how you
know how was school today did you do
your homework did you do this did you
get 10 out of 10 on your spelling test
and they'd probably be scrolling on
their phone half the time and the child
would feel that they weren't really
listening and this happened with men
women all different ages and then I'd
say okay
now try this with a friend
try to like have a you know conversation
where you really listen to them and you
don't interrupt them
and then they do that and then the next
stage would be with a colleague but
someday they've got a good relationship
with
and then by the time they started
feeling like yeah I can do this I can
really listen I don't have to like
sort of
answer back all the time we'd get them
to the point where they'd have a
conversation like that with somebody
that they haven't been getting on with
at work and that pathway was sort of
built in the brain by then so yeah what
sort of time period are we talking for
this to happen
it really depends how attention intense
the task is
so if it's something like
I want to start going to the gym three
times a week or I want to try
intermittent fasting it takes
two to three weeks to get that you know
to not feel like it's really difficult
when we're talking about things like
emotion intelligence or Intuition or
creativity we're talking more like
six to 12 months but I have this new
Theory which I haven't really shared
before which is that
if you really
focus on doing this in a nine month
period which is the gestation period of
a baby so from fertilization to a
newborn baby being born
you can essentially create a rebirth in
your brain by rewiring your neural
Pathways oh that's good it's a good
theory I like it that's very sticky it
makes sense it's like okay nine months
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by skillshare if you
haven't heard by now skillshare is one
of the world's leading platforms for
online classes for online education
they've got thousands and thousands of
classes on all sorts of topics from
business entrepreneurship lifestyle
design cooking interior design loads of
stuff and very excitingly I've actually
been teaching on skillshare since 2019
and I've got 13 classes on skillshare
yes 13 classes and you can access all of
them completely free of charge by going
to skillshare.com forward slash Deep
dive and that link will give you a free
one month trial to skillshare during
which you can watch any and all of my
classes one class you might be
interested in is my YouTube for
beginners class if you've ever thought
about starting a YouTube channel this is
the class for you I'll take you step by
step across like three four hours
something like that through all the
steps you need to take to make your
first two videos on YouTube how to do
the channel a lot if I think of a name
all of that fun stuff and loads of
people have taken that class and said
that that class was so good that they
would have literally paid hundreds of
dollars for it but you get it completely
for free on skillshare by going to
skillshare.com forward slash Deep dive
after your trial's over you can choose
to continue the subscription if you like
and you can access the thousands of
classes skillshare house from other
teachers including people that I know
people I'm friends with like Thomas
Frank and Nathaniel Drew but yeah the
main reason to check out skillshare of
course is that you want to check out my
classes if you want to learn about
productivity and video editing and
youtubing and even cooking so head over
to skillshow.com forward slash Deep dive
and thank you so much skillshare for
sponsoring this episode any other tips
for developing emotional intelligence uh
asking for a friend
oh I love that
um well so emotion intelligence is two
things which is one that you actually
understand and are able to regulate your
own emotions and then the second part is
that you understand what's going on
emotionally for somebody else and you
can respond to that in an appropriate
manner compassionate but not getting
sucked in
so in terms of the yourself part just
like naming how you're feeling so
finding a word for how you're feeling
and
you know
and I say this with from a position of
really caring but it's it's harder for
men to do that than women because of the
way that we're still brought up in
society which is Big Boys Don't Cry and
um you know don't don't be sad or sort
of so having a wider vocabulary for your
emotions and you can start off by either
just
you can check in with yourself every
hour and say how am I feeling
emotionally you can do it one to four
times a day you could Journal
um and then in terms of other people
just spent listening that's why that
listening exercise is so important and
listening without interrupting and
looking at people's facial expression
and stuff like that and so I would say
to you and this is obviously isn't going
to apply to everybody else but just in
the exact same way that you learned to
do a physical examination on a patient
you kind of go through that checklist of
like okay these are the things like what
am I seeing here is this person smiling
at me are their eyes welling up with
tears are they starting to raise their
voice is their voice quivering just
really paying attention to those things
so these high flying executives are
coming to you for help with a thing it
sounds like emotional intelligence was
like a big part it was a big stress and
so resilience distress and emotional
intelligence as a former psychiatrist
those were my bread and butter of
financial crisis resilience distress how
how does one train that
back to those Basics and I'll always
keep coming back to those Basics sleep
diet hydration exercise and mindfulness
um
and then yeah that that's the five like
really easy ways to think about it but
we have at Heights we have some like
more pillars around that like curiosity
and
um
and then I would use heart rate
variability technology to see what was
actually and show them what was actually
going on in terms of stress like how
well you're sleeping how stressed you
are during the day if there are any
periods of time hopefully whilst you're
sleeping but also during the day that
you find a way to recharge and like
rejuvenate your nervous system
what does that mean
okay so firstly like what's the deal
with heart rate variability I've heard a
few Tech Bros talk about oh hvr with
sleeping and stuff yeah never really
know anything about it and then what do
you mean by rejuvenate your nervous
system okay so these days you can um get
all sorts of gadgets from the aura ring
to the wood bracelet to the Apple watch
to the Fitbit that can monitor your
heart rate variability but I'm talking
quite a you know a decade or so ago I
was using
um
a heart rate variability monitor that
people would wear with like a a gel gel
sticker on their chest for three days
and three nights and I and it's just
color-coded data which shows
it's like turquoise when your
um your body's in the parasympathetic
state which is like Reston Digest
um and it's red when you're in the
sympathetic state which is stress
and then it's light blue or dark blue
depending on whether you're doing
moderate or high intensity physical
exercise okay so if you're doing a high
intensity exercise you would expect it
to be in sympathetic and then that's no
no no because it Compares heart rate and
heart rate variability if your heart
rate is elevated and therefore you're
physically exercising it's going to be
dark blue but if your heart rate isn't
elevated then depending on how your your
heart rate variability changes it shows
up more the psychological side which is
whether you're in sympathetic or
parasympathetic
and so is it
is it overly simple to say
parasympathetic good sympathetic bad
um
no I mean that's true you know it's true
but there's a reason that we have an
Adaptive response to stress which is
that sometimes you need to get away from
something that's bad for you so we we do
need that ability to get get into the if
you think about we say these words
without ever really thinking of them but
it's fright
flight fight and a fright is a threat so
you need to be able to you know get away
from a threat and that's the response is
that either flight you run away or fight
you respond to that threat in a in a
sort of equal manner
and then parasympathetic which is Medics
we would say is rest and digest but I
prefer to say rest and recharge because
you're not always digesting
um is when you recover from whatever
stress response you've had to go through
um during the day
so in if if we're thinking kind of Ideal
ideal work day would
would you always sort of be in
parasympathetic chill mode or is like in
sort of laptop work is it ever useful to
have a sympathetic response to a thing
I mean I think we have I it's very
different for different people so and
interestingly
a study
um showed that a nurse who was giving
cancer related
um news to patients and families all day
was actually in a flow State because
that was her purpose she was even if it
was bad news she was there for the
people
um the kind of people that I work with
they're in sympathetic all day really
yeah and sometimes even at night no wait
yeah that sounds terrifying that's why I
work with it that's why they want they
want to work with me I guess
um because I guess in like super high
flying careers where making like massive
trading decisions where there's billions
on the line when their job is at risk
like that's a high stress environment
and they're multitasking all the time
and they may be traveling a lot and they
may be jet lagged and they're
entertaining every evening and
um funnily enough one of the patterns I
saw which
I laughed with the person the first time
I saw it but then I saw it quite a lot
was that
they may be you know moderately stressed
and at some points maybe have flow
States but it was rare during the day at
work but they'd always be more stressed
when they got home and they had to see
their kids so that was interesting he's
he's Executives were were stressed
during the day but it was kind of
something that they could control but
then when it was like home and young
kids or Screaming kids or just being
pulled in two different directions they
they found that really stressful oh wow
okay so what do you think I can look at
my heart rate variability and it will
give me an idea of how stressed I am
throughout the day
is that it's really important to look at
Trends rather than a okay momentary
but we yeah I mean we could look at that
story yeah
um okay
rejuvenate your nervous system what does
that mean
well we should assume that we're quite
stressed during the day so there are
loads of Statistics that support that 70
75 percent of people in the western
world are way more stressed than they
should be all the time but they're like
chronically depleted of magnesium which
is a micronutrient that gets leeched up
by the body when we're stressed which is
why right from the beginning of working
with Heights I was like we need a
magnesium sort of flux
um
so we actively need to do things to help
to push our body into a state where it
can recover now
you might ask and people do ask me well
when we lived in the cave we didn't have
to like do mindfulness
but actually when we lived in the cave
yes we hunted and we had to avoid
predators and we had to avoid like
extremes of cold and hot and things like
that but we spent all our time in nature
we walked barefoot in nature we sat
around the campfire every night we
looked at the stars in the sky every
night there were natural ways of
recouping our resilience
and life was a lot more like a
short-term acute threat and then the
rest of the time a lot of recouping of
resilience these days we're bombarded
with information 24 7. we can be online
across time zones
all the time you know all day if we want
to
and so unless we specifically do things
to try to reduce that stress that our
brain and our body are under
that you know we basically essentially
lead to burnout
so what are the Beyond sleep hydration
exercise rest the the basic stuff that
we we've kind of talked about and would
be good to explore those more in more
detail what are some easy I guess easy
actionable things that people can do to
reduce stress levels
before I answer that I do
can't go on without repeating the
importance of Str of sleep because
there are still a lot of people that say
well I can get by on four or five hours
sleep or I don't need to sleep that much
or I'll sleep when I die I mean these
phrases are still around right but
actually getting enough sleep is
probably the single most important
foundation to
being able to recoup your resilience
during the day
the second one I would say we've talked
a lot about nutrition so I'll go on to
um
oxygenation of the brain and that is
either through formal exercise but what
I find with stress is that people start
to breathe in a shallow manner or they
hold their breath so a lot of people
when they're scrolling on social media
are actually holding their breath and
they don't really realize that and now
that I've said this to you
probably when people hear it they will
start realizing that they might be doing
that and you're already smiling so I'm
wondering if you're thinking that you do
it so just remembering to breathe deeply
is if you are at a desk
um you know on the laptop a lot of the
time then each hour when you check in on
okay how am I feeling emotionally also
just check in on like How Deeply you're
breathing and maybe just do 10 deep
breaths for the sake of it anyway why
why does deep breathing help because it
really does like I like anytime I have
like even even earlier when I was having
the conversation with Simon who's also a
coach and this morning interviewing Jim
who we were talking about compassion and
stuff
breathing came into it somehow and I
found myself being like
and realizing oh I actually have some
I actually don't read deeply very much
um and I tend to take very shallow
breaths and my singing teacher even
point that pointed the set he was like a
massive problem with your singing you
don't breathe anyone near deep enough so
when you're in the shower in the morning
you need to take 10 deep breaths and
it's just something that I just don't do
and there's something about it that
feels really good so what's what's going
on there
well it's good that you're doing singing
Because at least you're paying attention
to breathing which a lot of people
wouldn't so it's one of these things
we're not very conscious of old eggs
obviously it's happening 17 18 times a
minute we can't be paying attention to
that all the time
um stress is definitely the biggest
contributor to shallow breathing and
breath holding
um
so if we weren't stressed we probably
would we well not probably we would
naturally be breathing more deeply
and even if we're breathing normally
it's still good to take 10 deep breaths
because it does give that boost of
oxygen to the brain that's why it feels
so good because the brain's resources
are glucose and oxygen right I mean you
know that from basic physiology so
as long as you've eaten enough and
supplied the the glucose that the brain
can take up
within two or three hours of eating
then the second thing that you can
supply your brain with is oxygen if
you're tired but you don't have time for
a nap
do you have time to go for a walk if you
don't have time to go for a walk 10 take
10 deep breaths at your desk it it makes
a difference
you mentioned nature and looking at the
stars and stuff
what's inherently good about nature
yeah so this has really come up as a big
one in the last few years and I don't
I'm not sure if it's coincidental with
the pandemic and having been locked up
or or locked up but also had more
opportunity to maybe commune with nature
than we did in our hectic Lifestyles
before
but the brain benefits of time spent in
nature are massive
and
I whenever I'm asked a question that I
don't necessarily factually know the
answer to straight away always take it
back to evolution
there's a reason that our brains were
wider in a certain way and and when we
first became you know homo sapiens
we walked on the Savannah we we walked
in the land we we ate what we could hunt
fish or heart or harvest and so our
relationship with nature was was
you know we were dependent on it but it
was also a huge threat to us floods
storms you know fires
um it's the symbiotic relationship and
what we've done through Agriculture and
construction is just move ourselves
further and further away from that and
even if you just think of one like super
scientific example of that is that the
quality and diversity of our gut Flora
has diminished so much since we lived in
the cave it's it's like reduced by I
don't want to get the number wrong but
it's a shocking Factor like hundreds
um
and agricultures contribute to that
antibiotics have contributed to that to
that like obviously antibiotics save
lives and you know it's been an amazing
advance for us as humans but
um
the fact that we eat food that's
not as diverse as it used to be
that we
don't necessarily eat those Natural
Things the Prebiotic and Probiotic foods
and supplements that allow our gut
bacteria to flourish and we eat so much
processed food
um
and that stress alcohol and antibiotics
or damage I got microbiome
that's one of the huge consequences of
of um
having moved away from nature
and people ask all sorts of questions
that we don't know all the answers to
yet about why do we have more diseases
like me like Ms like autism like add and
some of the answers lie in that
disconnection from nature and what
that's done to how that's shaped our
bodies and our brains right
um and how we live as a result of that
damn cool so okay
um I mean I'm I'm just about to move to
Marley Bone which is fairly close to
Hyde Park so I I like the idea of uh
dab I've been dabbling with taking up
running and just running across along
Regents Canal at the moment but I really
like the idea of kind of running around
Hyde Park that seems there's something
about that that feels nice so we'll give
it a go and try and try and maintain the
Habit do another little thing for me
when you do that which is
just take one minute to look at a leaf
or a petal or
a squirrel or something like that's like
close up right in front of you in great
detail
and then take one minute to look at a
really large tree or building or a cloud
in the distance
and just see how that resets your
nervous system so there's a couple of so
that that's basically taking yourself
away from sharp Focus to
a wide Vista which is part of like
living in nature and on the Savannah is
that we we love having an uninterrupted
view of the Horizon it's really restful
for the brain yeah and then as well as
like 10 deep breaths you can just do
like you can take you can do a sharp
intake of breath and just do like a
really long sigh as well that's a nice
little way to reset your nervous system
um and then I did this
reel on Instagram that is called the
half salamander and it's a way to reset
your nervous system and I had no idea it
would get like 1.7 million views yeah
yeah so um it's a bit difficult to
explain but now but you look at that too
so those are three things the the sort
of looking in detail to looking in the
distance
sharpen take a breath and a big sigh and
then this house up there are three
really easy things that you can do yeah
this is something I I came across on the
huberman Lab podcast recently and around
like most of us spend most of our time
looking at near a thing and we almost
never actually look at something in the
distance and apparently there's
something like super legit about that is
that it's not partly why you know
speculating it feels so good to sort of
you know an ocean view where it's like
you can see the Horizon there's
something about that she's like stupidly
relaxing
um maybe there's something there okay so
we we've talked about
stress the end so okay so when you say
reset the nervous system by that do you
mean that most of us tend to be in
sympathetic mode in our work days and
just taking that moment to pause kind of
the Apple watch watch Breath breathing
it's just like okay we can chill it's
all good Tiger's not coming like it's
all good like body can relax
and
switching into parasympathetic mode into
rest in recharge mode
um naturally helps us kind of reduce the
code according to the level of release
of blood pressure it makes us feel great
and
also has all these positive health
benefits it's all of that stuff that you
said and for me the additional benefit
of it is knowing that I can control that
and that it's not completely dependent
on outside factors
so
you know to be honest sitting here with
you and chatting with you even though
obviously I'm thinking it feels like
really nice and relaxing and like we're
resonating we're both former doctors and
you know there's something
it's very like warm about that but
let's say if you were a different kind
of person and I felt maybe that you were
like really quizzing me with challenging
questions on purpose to try to trick me
up
then I could have a fright flight fight
response to that
or because I've trained myself in these
like ways to reset my nervous system and
longer term ways to build my resilience
I could find a way to not let you push
me into that state and knowing that that
I have the choice to do that that's
really really empowering yeah
what are some longer term ways to build
resilience
so here we're talking more like the
things I said would take like nine
months or more to build up so that's
having a really long-term journaling
practice long-term gratitude practice
practicing meditation yoga regularly
spending time in nature
um curating the sort of news and social
media information that you allow into
your brain
being very careful about the kind of
people that you hang around with I
I made a video recently uh where I sort
of had uh experimented with journaling
for 90 days and it was great like it was
so great and I now I've continued
journaling started bullet journaling as
well and I have this little
smart typewriter thing on my desk at
home which is like it's literally a
keyboard and all it has is one of those
e-ink Kindle like screens and all it
does is that you write on it and it just
connects to Wi-Fi and syncs it up with
whatever so you can't physically can't
get distracted doing anything other than
just the writing and so I've been using
that journal each night along with the
bullet journal and there's something so
nice about journaling um what does the
Neuroscience saw evidence say around why
journaling is legit
yeah so um
at the very minimum it's like a download
of your emotions and so with your you
know any emotions uh negative thoughts
unfinished tasks if you keep them in
your brain body system by just thinking
about them in your mind then you
actually increase your cortisol levels
and cortisol correlates with stress so
it's like it's like a pressure cooker
building up if you speak it out loud
write it out into a journal or do
physical exercise and literally sweat
out some of that cortisol then you're
releasing those negative emotions
negative thought patterns
anxieties you know worries about the
future from your brain body system
but I have and I'd love to know if
you've done this or not I have I had an
Insight which I just stumbled across by
myself but it really makes sense
obviously from the neuroplasticity point
of view is that if you go back and read
over your Journal you see your thought
process laid out in front of you you see
your patterns of behavior you see like
your decision making tools whether it's
more logical or more intuitive you see
what you've written about your
relationships with people and
seeing that in your own handwriting or
you know even if it's been synced up and
typed out for you just just seeing
knowing that it's your words and what
you've thought and what you've said
you can't run away from that so it can
be like so insightful and enlightening
and I've had that definitely with all of
that stuff like emotions and thought
patterns and intuition but
I also had it when I was I used to go to
Boston twice a year to teach at MIT and
I remember with the travel and the jet
lag just feeling that I was having these
small muscular twitches and it was
noticeable in bed at night
and
I decided to read back out not for that
reason but just anyway I decided to read
back over my journal from six months
earlier when I was last in Boston and
I'd written in my journal I'm getting
these little muscular twitches and so I
worked out that I'd become magnesium
deficient by flying and so I basically
hence why I was carrying so many bottles
of things with me when I was traveling
really upped my dose of magnesium
um for the trips and it never happened
again oh wow and if I hadn't read back I
would never put two and two together I
would have thought it was just happening
now and it hadn't happened before
what is the deal with magnesium
so I mean there are a lot of essential
micronutrients but magnesium is one that
underlies
lots of different physiological
mechanisms in the body so everything
from sleep to mood to
um neuromuscular Junctions
um to our joints our skin and so and and
it's very very easily depleted by stress
that's the thing so it's an important
mineral but there are quite you know
there's also zinc and calcium and other
important minerals potassium
but
it's one that's very easily depleted by
stress and that is a big you know
impactor on our brains in modern and
Western Society
um or really just in the modern world
so
when we're stressed and and the stats
show that 70 of us are sufficiently
stressed to be magnesium deficient
you cannot eat enough leafy greens and
nuts and seeds to replenish that you
have to supplement
and supplementation by powder or capsule
or tablet is fine but it's best taken
transdermally it's it's studies show
that taking magnesium transdermally
through the skin yeah like magnesium
patches
um not so much patches but gels lotions
I've bathing I bathing magnesium flakes
every day no way yeah wow okay so sorry
I'd rub you so Studies have shown that
there was a study that showed that it
was equivalent to taking IV no way yeah
bloody hell that's cool yeah how
so how how much rois are on this like
should I start bathing in magnesium
flakes for the minor benefit well I it's
not online it's not a minor benefit I
can physically tell the difference if I
haven't and if I you know choose to
shower for a couple of days in a row
instead of have a bath then I put three
handfuls of magnesium in instead of two
if I'm if I'm doing it if five days a
week let's say I'll do two handfuls
um what difference does it make what
have you found
um it helps with your sleep
if you do get so the one of the biggest
signs that your magnesium deficient is
that when you get one Twitchy eyelid you
ever get that
maybe I do but I don't remember but a
lot of people say say they do get it
yeah so
um I never get that if I'm regularly
bathing in magnesium
um but I you know I can get that
especially around the time of a lot of
travel involving jet lag
um other little most you know
musculoskeletal Twitches as well
um mood
and just emotional regulation your
response to stress you know it's it's
like some people say I can just about
hold it together when I'm at work but
when I get home if you know if my
partner's too demanding or my children
are playing up I just snap
so it's like how much does it take you
to snap if I
um you know if people are severely
deficient in magnesium then it's just
it's harder work to do the things that
you need to do to regulate your emotions
if you haven't put in the ingredients
that you're required to be able to do
that yeah and I guess like you know so
if someone has a seizure or something
like magnesium is is often on the list
of things to just whack in IV or
something yeah and if you know like the
biggest thing that I saw in medical
school that was just like such a shocker
like so easy to correct was when I did
care of the elderly and uh people got
UTIs and just how disorientated and
confused and
how how bad how awful it looked like the
state that they were in and you could
just like put in a bag of saline and it
would make a massive difference you know
and and obviously then we you would
check electrolytes and yeah that's good
so I I I'm not sure if it's just me but
like I feel like there's a lot of
skepticism around the idea of
supplements the idea that I oh I'm fine
uh like diet supplement companies equal
scam all of this kind of stuff
and a lot of Medics I know are also very
skeptical about supplements because like
well yeah you know there's a normal
range most people are in the normal
range Etc et cetera
but just like intuitively if someone's
electrolytes are a little bit off it can
make a massive difference to them and
you'd obviously you know whacking the
electrolytes if someone's fluid deplete
then it makes a huge difference to how
unwell they look and how and well they
feel and you give them from saline and
so and it's all good and yet
especially Medics even Medics like
should treat like drinking water like
you know most people I knew including
myself uh were more dehydrated than our
patients were when we were working
because it's just like you wouldn't take
the time to have some water and you'd
you know have a wee once a day and it
would be super concentrated and you're
like oh it's fine but you'd measure
someone else's uh you're an output and
you'd be like oh hello that doesn't look
very good two liters of saline and
apparently nurses get more kidney stones
than like most other professions because
they have the same thing they don't have
time to age to do or drink water
um yeah that's a really nice way of
putting and I would also say that for a
start most people are not in the normal
range for vitamin D for example
especially us with like darker skin but
pretty much you know in our in our
English weather a lot of people
regardless of skin color are vitamin D
deficient and that has a really
um
important correlation with future cancer
risk as well so you know it's an
important one to to supplement if you
are deficient
and
I would go back and say that I agree
ideally we would all get all of our
nutrition from our really nutrition
dense high quality organic you know
biodynamic food but the reality is that
most people are not eating in that way
and
I do try to eat in that way as much as
possible and but naturally I'm vitamin D
deficient I can't eat enough food to
correct that I have to supplement in the
winter months
um
so and magnesium I I know that I have to
and a probiotic I know makes a massive
difference to like my my gut health my
gut brain connection my immunity
um
so I do think it's really important to
know yourself really well but not
everybody's a medic and and Medics like
you said are often the worst at
neglecting themselves I feel like since
I've left medicine I've had more
personal benefit from the knowledge that
I have as a doctor that because I'm now
in health and well-being
um you know I'm one of those people that
can tell like two days before I'm coming
down with a cold or a flu and I can
sometimes even like well I haven't had a
cold or flu for years as long as I can
remember
um
and then at the other end of the
spectrum there are people who like the
day that they go on holiday they get
sick
because they've kind of been saving up
all that stress and like just trying to
get through the deadline kind of thing
so I think knowing yourself and then
understanding strategically which areas
you may need to supplement and that can
be from a blood test or it can be from
just understanding that if you're really
busy and stressed and you're feeling
fatigued that probably a vitamin B
complex could make a difference to that
try it if it doesn't make a difference
you don't have to take it again if it
does then keep taking it what sort of
time period would you expect a
noticeable change
I'd say one to three months depending on
the level of depletion okay and is this
the sort of thing that you have to
actively monitor your own response to it
that in terms of how am I feeling today
and Sample that or is it like oh damn I
feel so much better than I did three
months ago like what what sort of
response do people have
um I would say the SEC the latter is
more realistic right so just like a well
oh wow I've I've noticed myself I mean
okay if let's say you're going to invest
in taking something like heights yeah
which isn't cheap because it's doesn't
have any fillers in it or caking agents
and it's got high quality ingredients
and everything then
even then I mean let's be realistic you
tell me would you write down how
fatigued you're feeling every day I mean
like I've been taking Heights for a
while but and I've been but but I
wouldn't be able to even like I can't
tell the difference in my focus levels
when I'm dehydrated versus when I'm not
because of just like I I feel like I'm
just like this but I'm clearly not like
and so there's this level of
self-awareness of our own levels of
focus and our own levels of
stress in a way
and if I were to pull myself at almost
any day it's like how how how's my
contentment level I'd be like honestly
it's like 10 out of 10 like I can't
imagine being any happier and so I've I
find it hard to imagine a noticeable
effect of any kind of dietary supplement
if that makes sense so I'm actually I'm
actually the same as you so I obviously
look at all the studies that and the
surveys that we do for Heights and so I
have seen the percentage increase that
people have reported in things like
Sleep Quality and uh memory and
concentration
it doesn't make a noticeable difference
for me because of the way that I live
and eat and the supplements that I was
already taking
but I'm pretty sure that if I stopped
taking it and didn't eat quite as well
as I do I would notice a deterioration
so I think it's like the Delta it's like
how much difference is it making I apart
from vitamin D and probably magnesium
I'm not as far as I know deficient in
anything else but I'm assuming that the
way that I'm eating is enough to kind of
keep me
you know head above water but if I
supplement then I'm not risking going
below that threshold yeah I mean that's
why I subscribe to Heights because I'm
just like you know what I don't want to
even run the risk of a deficiency in any
of these things it's a fairly small
price to pay in the grand scheme of
things so why not and good studies good
and quality ingredients I'm never going
to eat 45 blueberries a day so why not
you know all that kind of stuff I'm
getting the um the Omega oils in a
palatable way is quite difficult as well
and and with Omega oils you do actually
have to like take them consistently and
I found that
the heights capsule is the easiest way
to do that so you know I'll have a
spoonful of fish oil I don't care about
the taste but
it's it's harder to make that into a
habit put it that way yeah
yeah I did a blood test uh with uh the
stuff when was it it was a couple of
months ago now
um I had a high Omega six to three ratio
which apparently means I eat too much
red meat and not enough fish yeah so I
am now making more of an effort to eat
more fish and eat less red meat um
that's good yeah Okay so we've talked a
lot about stress um you throughout the
term gut health and probiotics
oh I and the gut brain access what what
is going on there like I feel like this
is such a a thing that some people talk
about
six years of med school not once did
anyone mention the phrase got brain
access except maybe in a post script in
a physiology lecture in first year and
we had maybe two lectures on nutrition
which were awful in first year and
beyond that no one cared anymore like
what is going on with gut brain access
gut health like what is gut health how
how does it affect our lives so I don't
know when you're at medical school but a
lot of research has been done quite
recently on the gut brain access so
we've we've always known it existed like
you said it I think it was mentioned
once in pre-clinical but now well and
this is a really exciting I'm really
excited about this area of research so
the gut brain connection is now agreed
to be bi-directional so we used to think
that the quality of the gut microbiome
had an impact on your mental state and
and your brain power but now we know
that it's both it's it goes both ways
and that it is through
um
certain nerves but actually it's through
a much wider network of nerves than we
ever knew before
it's through
um cytokine messaging which is chemical
messages that get sent in the blood and
again are by bidirectional it's also
through hormones
um
so basically it's a complex dynamic
bi-directional system and that sounds
like I'm saying like everything and
nothing in one phrase so an
interestingly all the factors that
contribute to gut the health of your gut
microbiome so the back to the good
bacteria that live in your gut are the
same things we've talked about already
sleep
because when you um are jet lagged your
gut bacteria get jet lag too that's why
you go to the Loo at the wrong time of
the day and you're hungry at the wrong
time of the day hmm okay
and um obviously nutrition and hydration
would affect your gut and we
don't really understand why but doing
exercise improves the quality of your
and diversity of your gut bacteria as
well and then the psychological aspect
so some psychological therapies like CBT
cognitive behavioral therapy and
mindfulness practices
um we know more about the effects that
they have on certain receptors in the
brain but they also have Direct effects
on the gut bacteria
do we know how or is that our active
area of research I mean I think we know
that when we're stressed the gut can
become leaky and it can leak um hormones
into the bloodstream that then has an
effect on you know an inflammatory
effect on the rest of the body so I
think at the minimum we know that it's
reducing the pro-inflammatory effect
okay
how do I know if my gut health is good
or not good
is it the quality of my poo
it is so and actually you can have your
stool some thoughts sent off to a lab
and they can actually give you the
breakdown I I am going to do this with
Sophie from heights yeah like in the
next couple of weeks yeah
um yeah yeah I think she loves poo
apparently
um so as a doctor again of course you
you know you could examine it but most
people aren't going to do that and they
wouldn't know really
necessarily what what it meant by the
the color or the consistency and the
frequency and that kind of what does it
mean like uh what is Guy gold standard
when it comes to poo I um I I I I
haven't been a doctor for way longer
than you you should be answering that no
you've got the whole store chart thing
but they're like oh broadly if it's not
like a five or six on a still chart it's
probably okay but beyond that yeah I
mean I think you know
regular yeah and that's anything from
one or a few times a day to like a few
times a week
um it's just very individual so you need
to know what's right for you like the
color I would say either looks like
what you know you've eaten so for
example don't have a heart attack that
you've got blood in your stool if you
ate beetroot the night before
um
and
you know the consistency is basically if
it's too hard you're constipated if it's
too runny it's diarrhea and anything in
between is is fine and then things like
blood and mucus yeah there's also things
to look out for obviously
um but mostly if people do do a food
diary and they want to connect that to
their bowel movements and their mood
then it's
yeah it's kind of sort of like once or
twice a day if you go daily I would say
probably looking out for any change is
is the most important thing so and
that's with your urine and your stools
but if you really want to know about
your actual gut
microbiome you do have to send a sample
off so what does that tell you I think
it actually tells you like the names of
the different types of bacteria that you
have I haven't done like this myself but
I've been I've been offered to have my
poo sent to America but I've declined
um
because I eat so healthily and I take
probiotics I don't feel and you know
there's no issue in that department and
in particularly
feel a need to go that extra step with
that testing okay
what are probiotics and should everyone
be taking probiotics
so I'm going to go with the second part
of that question first because I I don't
like a one-size-fits-all solution I mean
I think it's a general advice to take
probiotics if you're traveling a lot if
you've taken antibiotics
if you are feeling stressed
if you do eat a lot of processed food
then
it's not going to harm people you know
and and like with everything with
medicine and looking after the health of
my loved ones often I do come back to
this Do no harm
um so
I think a good quality probiotic that's
out there if you took it for
6 8 12 weeks it's not going to harm you
and it's probably going to benefit you
um
I take one all the time and I I was I
was doing the after travel or a 12-week
Course once a year just to like give
myself a boost but from the beginning of
the pandemic I started taking one every
single day what does it do like
um benefit DC so it does help you to go
to the new regularly
and
it basically
it it replenishes the good bacteria that
are already in your gut and then the
Prebiotic foods like onion garlic
asparagus artichoke they actually feed
the bacteria that are then multiplying
in in your gut the good bacteria and so
for example when you take antibiotics
because that's killing bad bacteria in
your body wherever it is it also kills
all the good bacteria in your gut
um so and then you can have an imbalance
with things like
um fungus and
so it's basically keeping your gut in
good balance so that it can digest your
food
not leak bad things into your blood
system not cause you to get bloated or
irregular and and send good signals to
the brain and and there is a connection
between
um the bone marrow cells that are
responsible for our immunity and the
quality of our gut microbiome as well so
these kind of longer connected Fields
like if when we connect up Endocrinology
which is the hormones with Immunology
which is our immune system and
psychology and neurology
um there's such a thing as immuno psycho
um you know Endocrinology which is the
connection between our mental state our
hormones and our immune system and so
all of our systems I think are connected
in a much more complex and dynamic way
than we understand but that gut
microbiome does seem to be almost like
stem cells for a lot of you know others
important systems in the body and when
it comes to food choices that are good
bad for your gut
is that like an individual thing like
some people resp some people's guts
respond really well to red meat and
others don't or are there some general
principles around what what sorts of
foods are good for your gut
so there are general principles like
um plant-based and hydrating foods and
hydrating food like cucumber and melon
so foods that obviously have a lot of
water in them because you actually
retain more water from
food that is high in hydration than just
drinking water that's that tends to run
through yeah
um
foods that are high in antioxidants
um
the good fats pretty much everything
that we were saying earlier so like you
know that healthy diet bit of fish and
seafood not too much meat the real
no-nos are processed food smoked food
um too much alcohol antibiotics
and and the real kind of yeses for the
gut microbiota the fermented foods
that's sauerkraut kimchi Cafe kombucha I
try to have one of those things almost
every day and then there are some more
genetic things to think about so for
example for a while coconut oil was a
big craze particularly for the medium
chain triglycerides the MCT oils
genetically come from a country where
coconut trees grew
you're more likely to be able to
tolerate coconut oil in your gut and for
it to not affect your lipid profile too
much then if you start taking a lot of
MCT oil in your coffee but genetically
you weren't really made to metabolize
coconuts that well and so the meat thing
is probably also along those lines so
depending on where your genetic Heritage
came from
um whether a lot of meat was eaten or
not
having read your book it strikes me that
you are somewhat into Eastern
spirituality practices like yoga
meditation manifestation affirmation
type stuff
and
I first read the secret a couple years
ago and I was like there's no way anyone
can take this seriously and then I saw
how successful it was I was like oh wow
people are taking this seriously and
then I read your book recently I think
it was like last month
yeah yeah very recently um and I was
like oh you know maybe there is
something to this manifestation type
stuff
but then around around the same time
I've started to dabble with books around
spirituality and basically 100 of them
talk about meditation and like 90 of
them talk about yoga and so clearly
there's something going on here which
benefits us and which science seems to
have
sort of scratched the surface of but not
really what is your take on all the
stuff how should a normal rational
thinking person approach the realm of
spirituality broadly
um well I've probably been on a similar
journey to you in that
it was very difficult for me to accept
something that wasn't evidence-based and
I partly started the research from my
book to to convince myself that there
was an Evidence base for the laws of
attraction that's where it started I
spent one summer holiday
researching what the laws of attraction
were
finding out that there wasn't even
necessarily agreement about exactly what
they were but kind of you know whittling
it down to the most commonly agreed 10
or 12. and then just trying to apply the
cognitive science to it because I'd
heard about all the the quantum science
and the vibrations and things but I felt
like well if it's to do with the power
of your thinking surely it should be
explained by cognitive science so let me
see if I can do that and it was
surprisingly easy to explain most of the
laws of attraction through cognitive
science and
the one or two that maybe I couldn't
find evidence for I sort of came to that
point of where what I said to you
earlier which was I don't think it's
going to harm you so if you're happy to
do it without the evidence do it and if
you don't want to do it without the
evidence then don't
um
and then
through that I became much more
interested in visualization but I had
personally been doing vision boards
really successfully for over a decade by
the time I wrote my book
um and so understanding more about the
Neuroscience of The Selective filtering
that your brain does and the selective
attention that you can choose to page
certain things and the way that your
brain tags what's important in value to
it in your brain you know that was all
like okay wow and and what was really
gratifying is that people who weren't
scientists at all
said that understanding that the science
that there was science and what it was
made them actually do something like a
vision board or visualization where
they'd heard of it before but never
actually bothered to do it
and
but then
being a you know senior lecturer at MIT
and my previous book being Neuroscience
for leadership and working with the kind
of people that I do in financial
services
I suppose it was a bit of a risk to go
out there with a book that's about
science and spirituality and suddenly
start being more open about the fact
that I do yoga and you know I grew up
with meditation and
um but the response to my book
that actually had a huge impact on me so
by doing the research I was I was like
yeah this is legit
um and now I understand even better like
how it works and that contributes to me
being able to do visualization and
manifestation better
but just seeing
like the amazing impact it had on people
seeing just seeing the numbers go up of
the international translations I mean on
the day that my book came out in the UK
I'd already signed 24 International
translation contracts and now I think
we're up to 38 and that means it's
having global appeal that people of all
different
races and cultures and religions and
belief systems
it's it's got that appeal and and you
know I absolutely love neuroscience and
psychology and neuroplasticity and so
that tells me that
personally that Journey for me was that
it's okay to go out there and talk about
stuff that you believe in in private and
not keep it completely separate to your
professional life
and
so yeah you know I grew up with yoga and
meditation in the household but I just
wanted to fit in and be like my friends
in London who didn't grow up with those
things and those things circled back to
me later in life and now it's cool to be
into those things anyway so
um but the bit you know both yoga and
meditation are forms of mindfulness so I
use that as an umbrella term like sport
and then under sport there's all sorts
of different sports and under
mindfulness there's meditation there's
yoga there's spending time in nature
there's barefoot walking there's eating
mindfully there's paying attention why
is mindfulness good for you
I'd love to put that back onto you and
say
how could it be good to be mindless you
know thoughtless not paying attention
like Okay so this the specific citizen
scenario I have in mind is
um
so I walk I walk here every morning I
have a nice half an hour walk by the
canal it's all very nice
um
this morning like most mornings I have
an audiobook on at like 3.5 times speed
and I was listening to the Bomb by some
author which is about the history of the
nuclear Arsenal and how that evolved
from the 1960s up to up till the present
day because I was just like I want to
learn more about the topic it's kind of
cool and so I've got this like if if
someone were to
see that they would be like this is the
archetypal example of toxic productivity
this guy is a psychopath and a sociopath
he's office rocker like what what the
[ __ ] is he listening to a book of 3.5
times speed can't even understand what's
going on about running like nuclear arms
proliferation
and I quite liked it I was like you know
I was walking by the canal and listening
to this book I've got like three podcast
interviews today where I can have cool
conversations with people like life is
good
but part of me is like yeah but what if
I did what if I took the airpods out
what if I just kind of enjoyed the walk
and walked mindfully and stuff
and I've tried that a few times and I
haven't noticed a
I don't feel as if like I'm suddenly way
more stressed if I'm listening to an
audiobook at three times a week to
compared to if I'm not and so but I
wonder if I'm missing something that's
that's kind of why I ask okay yeah so am
I your third person of today yeah yeah
okay so and I'm using that to assess you
because I know that three in a day is
like the maximum that I can do and with
that third one I start
feeling a bit like did I ask that
question to Taro or did I ask that
person you know that question to the
person that was with earlier because it
all starts to like merge into one a
little bit so you've you feel so alert
and engaged I think you're like
definitely in your happy place and good
at this and like nothing's detracted
from your mental performance
and you know you're also at that stage
in your life like your age and and where
you are with your business that you want
to be absorbing all this information and
doing like as much as as you can
but maybe it's about just understanding
that there's some there is definitely
there is something good in terms of
cortisol levels and
um about spending some time where you're
not always doing okay yeah and
I'm guessing and we'd have to keep in
touch to prove that this is true that as
you get older that that might change so
I think I don't know how old you are but
I'm pretty sure 28. okay so I'm a lot
older than you well okay
um so yeah when I was 28 I could I could
do you know I mean I because of how long
I was at University I was probably a
junior doctor when I was 20. I think um
how old was I
around that time 27 28
um yeah 27. so yeah you know I did like
weeks of nights on call on a vascular
surgery Ward and like got up and went on
holiday the next day and like still
socialized and yeah okay now that I know
how young you are that yes it's your age
you're able to do all those things okay
so if I so is it is the idea and I guess
for people listening to this that if if
someone does notice a deterioration in
their mental performance and or like oh
I find myself unable to concentrate at
that point they're like okay let's
assess and figure out what you're doing
across all these different domains so I
would say that you know you're so young
and and obviously you said that you're
very happy so I'm assuming that like
nothing has like seriously affected your
health or your mental health or whatever
so but so but I wouldn't say wait till
that starts to deteriorate because one
of the things
that I really really felt for myself
during the pandemic
was how much better off I was because I
had been proactive about building up my
mental resilience and my mindfulness so
for example I have always as far as long
as I can remember since I was a child I
was taught it as a child but as an adult
it was such an ingrained Habit to eat
mindfully so I always pause before I
take my first mouthful I always give
gratitude I try to not speak when I'm
eating
I don't mind if other people do but I
try and I never ever watch television or
have it on in the background or have my
phone anywhere near me when I'm eating
and
so what I found in lockdown where
obviously we were forced to be in a way
that wasn't natural for us that we
didn't necessarily want we were also in
terrible fear of what could happen to us
if we you know didn't adhere to these
restrictions that
I didn't really have to think about
being mindful because I had those three
meals a day where I was that was a
mindfulness practice for me I was very
fortunate I was able to spend time in
nature and just the way that I chose to
interact with people because suddenly
when you're working from home
I started off sitting at the kitchen
table and that meant that anyone that
walked past me thought I wasn't working
so they would just talk to me and my
first response was to feel like I'm
trying I'm in the middle of an email
like that's a bit annoying and then I
thought what's more important this email
that can finish in five minutes time or
that a member of my family wants to talk
to me and so then I would turn and give
my full attention and say
yes I'm really interested in you know
what what you have to say and then not
you know within a few weeks I've moved
myself out of the kitchen
um
so there were there were times that I
thought this is such it's not life or
death it's not important but I became so
depressed at one point that we couldn't
go on holiday
and and I just had you know a really
down day where I felt really sorry for
myself and I allow myself that from time
to time
but
you know I I did think if I hadn't done
all of the Gratitude and journaling and
you know that kind of stuff before there
were quite a few things that could have
dragged me like downwards much more than
they did yeah
so when it comes to yoga for example and
like yoga and meditation
it seems like at least from the stuff
I've read and the way people describe it
there is something more than just
mindfulness going on uh
but where people describe kind of these
out of body experiences and kind of the
death of the ego and like connecting
with the world and feeling energy and
all of that stuff
have you had experience of that like how
do you how do you think about that as
like a scientist and a doctor
um yeah a scientist and a doctor I
wouldn't use that terminology
um yoga actually you know in Sanskrit
means Union and it's the union of the
mind and the body and mindfulness and in
meditation are that connection between
the mind and the body so understanding
that the the mind is embodied it's not
just in your brain it's everywhere and
and being one so Union in that way
so
I would I would say that those things
are mindfulness that when you practice
them regularly your cortisol levels are
lower than people age matched people of
the same gender that don't
I I can't speak to those individual
experiences but that's not phraseology
that I yeah awesome yeah um yeah I'm 16
days through the uh Sam Harris waking up
meditation course
um I was reading some stuff around
non-duality non-dual meditation and sort
of this how people who unlock the
ability to experience that and feel like
it's been life-changing and so I was
like I mean that sounds pretty cool so
I'll give it a go see see what happens
well let me know how you go at the end
of the 30 days yeah we'll do it yeah
we'll do like there's some Studies have
been done on that app that found that I
think like
uh the start I read was like 10 of users
who complete the 30-day course say that
they it taught to them non-deal
meditation and of those half of them
said it was like the most life-changing
thing they've ever done okay those are
sufficiently good odds that yeah I
expected value why not but I I would
really really like trust and respect
your opinion on your experience at the
end of it you would oh yeah yeah yeah
I'll I'll report back when it comes to
mindfulness and this genre of stuff um
again what are some actionable things
that someone listening to this could do
that are fairly non-oruduous that would
have a big uh or a potentially help them
level up in terms of kind of stress
reduction spirituality this sort of
thing I mean some of the things that
we've discussed already so like paying
attention to your breath that's a really
minimal one mindful eating is a favorite
one of mine
what is mindful eating like well the way
that it started for me in lockdown was
that because I had no boundary between
work and home I I sort of had I could
either do a time like six o'clock
because
that's I can do all my us work in that
time and still not be too late and then
my like chopping of my vegetables in the
kitchen and preparing dinner that was
that was like a mindfulness activity for
me
um so I'd be like very very focused on
that not didn't want any distractions
around well so you're not listening to a
podcast or an audio oh my goodness okay
um I said occasionally I might but but
really really occasionally like not not
Morgan you're just fully focused on like
chopping the thing yeah okay yeah
peeling chopping and because I compost
so they're knowing that it's going back
into nature thinking about things like
the bite size that it's going to be for
the person I'm going to present it to
like really like thinking it all the way
through and then mindful eating is just
that you sit down you're mostly you're
quiet that you give gratitude for your
food and then you just you you just eat
your food you don't do anything else
oh my goodness yeah what a radical
thought and you appreciate the flavors
and stuff like without watching TV
without like doing other stuff yeah
because I find that if I'm like I'm
often so mindless while eating oh I've
just eaten a whole plate of stuff I
don't even know if I was full like I
haven't really enjoyed the food but I've
just been like watching a YouTube video
a double speed or something while doing
so oh my goodness and then my girlfriend
is big into mindful eating so
occasionally like you know we should try
eating mindfully yeah that's a good idea
you know let's try that no that's good
you've got that influence and look I'm
not one of these neuroscientists that
doesn't watch TV I love TV I watch so
much TV including trash so it's not a
comment on that at all it's just about
if I'm picking that as one of my
mindfulness activities then I've got to
be focused on that at the time and I you
know I also do a lot of barefoot walking
um well what's the deal with that like
why is that just because it feels like a
connection with nature yeah it's like
it's it's a grounding practice so it is
it it just can it connects you to Nature
um
some people believe that it has you know
an effect on the electromagnetic field
but it's just it's more just being in
nature and being Primal like we were
when we lived in the cave and
yeah that you know that's an exercise of
staring into the distance I really love
that one but I think probably the most
important one in life
is paying attention to people that you
love because
you can be half paying attention whilst
you're watching a YouTube video on two
point five times speed and that's not
really love is it you know so I think
having that time with people where
you're like together you're giving each
other that eye contact your like
genuinely listening to that person
you're sharing things that they know are
it's special that you're sharing it with
them
um and just share you know sharing
experiences but also kind of doing it
mindfully
I think reading can be mindfulness and
for me swimming is like my most mindful
activity so I do I do like running I do
like my my exercise bike
but swimming is the most mindful one for
me
amazing
um
we talked a little bit about vision
boards like what is a vision board and
how like how how do I get started with
making a vision board if I want to do
the thing okay so a vision board is
essentially a collage made by hand where
you actually have magazines and you cut
images out and stick them down
you can do it digitally
um
but I actually prefer to call them
action boards because
a little bit like what you were saying
earlier about the secret is
that
and I'm not saying this is said in the
secret but there is this idea that you
can create this fantasy of the life that
you want and sit at home and wait for it
to come true and do nothing about it and
I think the science but also just
my like way of going about life is that
yeah create that dream that ideal and
and and do the collage and have it
somewhere in your house that you look at
it all the time
and visualize it becoming true
but also you have to go out there and do
things to make it come true you know if
you say oh I really want to get married
and have a baby well then start looking
after your health and meeting suitable
people rather than going out partying
all the time you know if you think I
really
like hate my job but it pays the bills
but I'd love to you know go off and be a
freelance whatever then ask yourself
what you can actually do about that who
can you are you know ask your network to
introduce you to that might help to move
you closer to that
um
so everything from like really really
little steps all the way up to
perhaps bigger things that you could do
that maybe you have to build yourself up
to a little bit but so so I really say
yeah I make a board once a year I keep
it somewhere visible and it's fine to
keep it visible only to you and not
necessarily visible to others but I keep
mine visible to others so I'm like I
have No Reservations about talking about
these things that I want I'm not ashamed
of them I believe that I deserve them so
anyone can look at them and when I
started up my business that included the
amount of money that I need wanted to
earn each year so you know the kind of
thing that not everybody tells everybody
about but I for me like it's out there
um and then looking at it
at least well looking at I say at least
daily I keep Mine by my bed so I can
look at it twice daily
or I naturally look at it twice daily
without even thinking
um
believe visualizing it becoming true and
having the absolute belief that it will
and one I've added in more lately is
like giving gratitude that that this is
coming true like it's unfolding now even
if you can't see all of it yet
um and then going out there and doing
something however small to move yourself
towards those things
and what's the science behind how this
stuff works
so it is back to something I briefly
mentioned earlier which is selective
attention selective filtering and value
tagging and that is that
we're so bombarded with information in
the modern day that what you would read
in a newspaper in one day today is the
amount of information that somebody
would have received in their lifetime
100 years ago
and even a hundred years ago people were
overly bombarded with information so
it's gone exponential and so for similar
reasons to how we're not aware of our
clothes on our body all day the brain
naturally filters out things that aren't
vital to our survival
and
if we are not mindful then that's being
chosen subconsciously without us having
any you know impact on that
and
but if we do something like create a
vision board or visualize something that
we want then we're training the brain
more to be aware of the things that we
really want so that so then when it does
the selective filtering it doesn't
filter out
that person that could introduce you to
somebody about your business or that
person that could introduce you to
somebody for a date it you know because
you might think well that's not really
important for me today I need to put
food on the table I need to get this
document done
but those sort of more long-term
important things the brain will just not
filtered them out and then you're more
likely to pay attention and basically
that means noticing and then grasping
opportunities that can move you closer
to your goal and the value tagging is a
system
that literally tags in order of
importance of things that you want in
life but it's partly logical and partly
emotional so logical will be the very
basic fundamental
these are the things I need to survive
and then the emotional will be more like
your wishes and your desires
um like the innermost things the longer
term things and often logical trumps
emotional so you have to like move that
balance and keep reminding yourself
these are the things that I really want
and then your brain adapts to you rather
than you just
being kind of
not the kind of driver of the journey
okay yeah so
I remember this was one of the things
that most struck me when I was when I
was listening to the audiobook of your
book while doing this canal walks
actually I was thinking okay I'm gonna
make a vision board and then I found
some online whiteboardy software I think
Ian started posted a photo of Zac Efron
with six-pack abs on it I was like cool
body gold and then I just never looked
at it because it was never a thing that
I would look at but since I've started
building uh since I've started bullet
journaling recently this is now a thing
that I look at every day where I've got
my my goals and things that I was like
oh yeah I did have try and do a stand-up
comedy thing on my list of goals
and so yesterday I was interviewing
someone who's done stand-up comedy and I
remembered oh yes I was like hey do you
want to do a YouTube collab or you
helped me do a stand-up comedy setting
yeah sure and I think I I wrote that
goal like two months ago and had I not
looked at it I would would have
forgotten that that was even a thing
that I wanted to do because I was so
focused on like you know let's let's
make this podcast good that's like every
every other thing that got in the way so
I love the idea of having like a
physical board where I can like stick
stuff on it and actually just shove it
on my bedside so I can look at it twice
a day and I feel like that would almost
certainly have benefits
um how how like how do you do it do you
divide it life into eight different
areas and do it like that or what what's
your kind of actual process for this see
and do it like that
like that comb love Health whatever but
um you don't have to but I I pay more
attention to I do tend to group things
and I like to leave some space because I
am not arrogant enough to think that I
can think of all of the most amazing
things that could ever happen for me so
I like to leave a bit of space for Magic
I do choose which sections touch each
other and which sections don't so things
like home and life they have to be in
Balance but you know some things like my
own personal like fitness goals don't
necessarily have to be completely
connected to those two things
um
and I think positioning is important so
things like
and it's just what it means to you you
know things that are at the top could be
like that's top priority things at the
bottom could be that's foundational you
know it just kind of depends but I think
it's good to be intentional about that
yeah how big a canvas do you use I don't
use a massive one I use a
half the size of that oh okay yeah and
then do you get print off images but
I've had a bigger one than that as well
in lockdown I did a really big one nice
yeah and you print things off would you
buy some magazines and cut things right
so the reason I wanted to come back to
this because you said you did a
whiteboardy thing is the reason I do
magazines is that if you print stuff off
that means you are limiting yourself to
what you can think of
because you've got to go and search for
it when you look through magazines
you'll find images that you're drawn to
and you need to work out why or so I try
not to use words that much but sometimes
there's a phrase that really just
captures what you want and so it is good
maybe if you're very sure about some
things sure look them up and print them
off but do go through some magazines
because then you might see something
that you didn't expect oh that sounds
great I'm just imagining like this this
will actually make for an interesting
video as well like starting like you
know I tried a vision board for 30 days
you know starting with the science of
manifesting and how that works and then
being like all right
if I want to do it like this year rather
than in January yeah yeah well you need
to do it before January so it's like
fully set up for January oh yeah nice
that's a good shot actually yeah and it
doesn't even have to be January
September's like back to school yeah
okay cool I'm sold when's your birthday
May okay so it's another time yeah
that's a great shot okay I'm sold Vision
boarding here we come
um I'm gonna buy some magazines cut some
things out I've I've really started to
like the analogness of stuff since
starting the bullet Journal thing and
getting like a Polaroid camera and this
is something nice about you know flexing
that like old
Secondary School muscle just like
highlighting things and making stuff
look pretty and yes the the tactile
nature or something in an otherwise very
like sort of online digital type life
well that's actually part of of the of
my process as well which is that when
you do a vision board it's it's color
it's tactile it's not just you know it's
different to writing a list so it is
stimulating your other senses
well what sort of stuff Have you had on
the vision board in the past that's kind
of come true
um yeah sounds weird to say but yeah
true so I've had a lot of things
um one of them was in the first year of
my business
the thinking about how much money I
wanted to earn and working out how much
I needed to live
and then a friend challenging me and
saying well that's not really very
vision board like you should double it
and I said but that's absolutely not
realistic for this you know first year
and but I did I found the number that
was double and I liked it and I put it
on there and sure enough I uh so so I
was like okay or I could double this
again
and so I did doubling for quite a few
years and then then eventually it flat
out because I can't like I'd have no
more hours
um yeah and
when I was buying my first flat after I
got divorced I found a picture of a
kitchen and a bathroom that I liked and
they were on my vision board and I liked
the kitchen but it had one orange wall
and I didn't like the orange wall but I
liked everything else about the kitchen
and
the bathroom I liked everything about it
but it had a wooden Lucy which I didn't
like either but I liked everything else
and the first flat that I bought the
kitchen had an orange wall which my
ex-husband then painted white for me and
it had a wooden seat which I also
changed
um
and then
I you know lots of travel specific
travel places I wanted to go to lots of
Business Schools writing the book you
know had like an old-fashioned
typewriter on my vision board one year
and then
in 2015 I realized you know I've been
divorced for quite a long time
I was working like a maniac
and I just realized that I was kind of
running away from
opening up my heart again
so for the year of 2014 it was all
travel and business and I put a tiny
heart on it and like nothing happened
so at the end of 2015 I thought okay if
I really believe in this vision board
stuff
I should open myself up to doing it for
love as well as like work and travel and
um
and I found a picture of like a a
prominent engagement ring in a newspaper
and I put that on the top left because
left is like left hand and heart and
everything
and then
I found this phrase and I don't like I
said I don't normally use phrases but it
said Joy comes out of the blue and it's
just really really spoke to me I can't
tell you why and I put that top Center
and then I had some Housey stuff
and I had a rhino and a tiger because I
was interested in conservation
um I'm trying to think what else was on
it
that those are the main things
and so I made that in December 2015
in on the February 2016 so like a month
and a bit later
I met the person that I was going to
marry on a plane so that's Joy comes out
of the blue because we met in the sky
and three months later we were together
six months after that we were engaged
a year later we got married and we
didn't ask for gifts we chose Charities
and I chose a conservation charity and
the Housey stuff that I'd put on there
looked exactly like the house that we
then renovated I mean that that vision
board stays by my bed because it's a
reminder that
that's how specific you can be and like
how things can come true and it's really
incredible and since then it's been more
back to like work work stuff and travel
yeah
that's really cool
um so someone a bit skeptical listening
to this might be like okay come on
you've been Vision boarding for 10 years
let's say you've got 20 items in a
vision board that's 200 items worth of
stuff like almost by chance some of them
are bound to come true and then you're
going to tell yourself a story that oh
these things came true and therefore Dot
and I think it's similar to the skeptic
attitude towards like oh I was thinking
about this person and they rank it's
like well you you probably think about
20 people a day and they don't ring but
the one that works at the one that you
remember
um
how how do you think about like
that versus yeah that kind of response
to Vision body manifesty type stuff
which I've I've come across on the
internet yeah so there is such a thing
as confirmation bias which is obviously
that when something gets proven right
that we we take that as evidence that we
were right and when something doesn't
get proven right we forget about it
there is you know there is that I'm not
going to deny that but
I personally and and I have so many
messages from people who read my book
and listen to me on podcasts have been
so specific about the things that I've
asked for and if I look at the ratio of
the things that I put on my board that
have come true some of them have taken
longer some of them haven't come true
yet it's
it's an impressive statistic if if you
know it was going to be random it's way
more than random so
and and it really comes back to
the fact that it must be true that if
you know what you want and you put your
mind to it and you take steps towards
achieving it it's more likely to happen
and
so with these sort of
ideas that well
it could be just that you're noticing it
because of confirmation bias or it could
be that you were lucky
or it could be that you've got more
opportunities in Life or whatever all of
those things could be true but you could
also make your life better and get more
things in your life that you want if you
were just open to these things
absolutely I love it
um final thing I'd like to ask you about
if you're open to it and we can
absolutely cut this if you're not um so
and I'm asking for selfish reasons um
any lessons like that you're taking away
from Marriage number one that you're
applying to marriage number two that
could abstract to other like
relationship advice for for other people
yeah that's I don't know um
I mean in general I would say that my
journey
between marriages was when I you know I
got divorced when I changed career so
all of that stuff like reading jungian
psychology looking into Buddhism looking
into like the laws of attraction
um soul-searching for myself and
starting really on the path of more
mindfulness and gratitude and journaling
and and resilience training
all of those helped me to
become the person that I was by the time
I got married again and it was nine
years between marriages so quite a long
time and obviously my career had
completely changed
and
look like a normal human I carried some
of the the issues that I had from the
first marriage into the beginning of the
of the relationship but
I'd have to say
obviously I was more mature and I I knew
more
but really one of the biggest thing I
learned was that even though I'm a
doctor and I got a PhD in neuroscience
and I've done a lot of personal
development
I just met someone that was so lovely
and amazing and kind and generous and
tolerant of all my little bad habits and
stuff I
uh it was just easy I was lucky yeah
um
it may not have worked out like that but
yeah yeah but people often say that like
oh it's we can marriages are hard and
it's the effort you put into it and
stuff and then some people are like well
if you find the right person it doesn't
feel like effort yeah it sounds like
you're more in the second count well I
think I mean I I'm probably not giving
myself enough credit for all the
personal development that I did but I
also met somebody very compatible so
yeah I didn't it didn't take that much
effort but and also my my first husband
is still like an incredible person as
well so
we were just young yeah exactly well
Tara thank you so much it's been
wonderful um any uh final asks that you
have for the audience who might be
watching or listening to this
well it would be lovely if they follow
me on Instagram at Dr Tara swart and if
they were interested in reading my book
um but they can also listen to me on
podcasts and I actually have my own
podcast launching called reinvent
yourself with Dr Tara which is about
neuroplasticity and it's stories of
people's life changes so if they'd like
to listen to that too that would be
amazing fantastic and we'll put links to
all of those things in the show notes
and the video description and of course
a link to Heights which is a supplement
that you work with I'm an investor in
and both of us take on yeah on the daily
that's a sotara thank you so much thank
you all right so that's it for this
week's episode of Deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye